WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET SO
WE'LL WAIT UP FOR THE QUORUM IN
ORDER TO DEAL WITH ITEMS THAT
ARE VOTE ONLY.
BUT WE WILL GO --
TO ITEM FIFTY TWO TWENTY FIVE
ISSUE.
ONE WHICH DEALS WITH THE CAPITAL
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION CAPITAL OUTLAY IN
FACILITY IMPROVEMENT
PRIORITIZATION AND MASTER PLAN
FOR RENOVATION PLACE ONE OF
ORIGINAL.
PRISON STUDY BUDGET PROPOSAL.
ON PAGE.
THREE SO WILL BEGIN WITH THAT
I'D.
OUR PANELISTS IS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
PART OF FINANCE IN THE LA --
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I AM -- ERIC
SWANSON DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF CDC
OURS OFFICE OF FISCAL SERVICES.
THIS FIRST ISSUE DEALS WITH A
WIDE ARRAY OF IT --
AREAS OF EXPERTISE AT CDC ARE SO
WE KIND OF ARE TAKING A PALE
APPROACH TO IT --
THE ONE BUDGET ACTION ON THE
AGENDA IS A REQUEST TO EXTEND
THE REVERSION DATE.
OF FIVE POINT FOUR MILLION FOR A
STUDY THAT WILL.
LOOK AT THE STATE PRISON IS
CONSTRUCTED PRIOR.
TO NINETEEN EIGHTY HOWEVER THE
AGENDA ALSO ASKED THE DEPARTMENT
TO DESCRIBE.
KIND OF THE FACTORS THAT GO INTO
OUR MAINTENANCE AND CAPITAL
OUTLAY DECISION MAKING.
SO WITH ME TODAY IS DEBORAH
HYSON.
DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION OF
FACILITY PLANNING CONSTRUCTION
MANAGEMENT.
KATHLEEN ALISON ACTING'S
UNDERSECRETARY OF OPERATIONS.
AND JULIE BASCO WHO HAS A REALLY
LONG TITLE BUT I'M GONNA SHORTEN
IT.
SHE'S DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
RESEARCH OKAY FINE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MY NAME IS DEBORAH HYSAN I'M THE
DIRECTOR FACILITY PLANNING
CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT FOR THE
DEPARTMENT.
I'M GOING TO GIVE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW ON HOW WE PRIORITIZE
OUR CAPITAL OUTLAY --
PROJECTS BUT I WANTED TO
INDICATE THAT THE PRIVATIZATION
PROCESS FOR CAPITAL OUTLAY.
IS NEARLY IDENTICAL TO THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE ITEM AND
ITEM TWO AND SO INSTEAD OF BEING
REDUNDANT THERE I THOUGHT IT
MIGHT BE GOOD TO SHOW TO SHOW
YOU HOW WE DO THAT.
AND WHY THAT MIGHT BE IMPORTANT
AS IT FEEDS INTO HOW WE'RE GOING
TO BE DOING OUR TWELVE PRESENTS.
SO JUST A BIT OF BACKGROUND ON
THE DEPARTMENT OPERATES THIRTY
FOUR STATE OWNED FACILITIES --
OVER FORTY THREE MILLION SQUARE
FEET AND ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND
STRUCTURES.
ARE FACILITIES ARE OLD EVEN OUR
NEWER PRISONS HAS A REFER TO OUR
OLD 60% OF OUR FACILITIES AT OUR
IN FACT THIRTY YEARS OR OLDER.
AND 35% OR FIFTY YEARS OR OLDER.
AND WHAT WHAT THIS MEANS TO US
IS THAT WE'VE GOT CONDITIONS IN
OUR FACILITIES WHERE THE USEFUL
LIFE THAT WAS PLANNED FOR THAT
FACILITY.
HAS LONG SINCE EXCEEDED AND SO
IN RECOGNITION OF THAT IN TWENTY
ELEVEN WE PERFORM SOME CONDITION
ASSESSMENTS.
WITH AN OUTSIDE CONSULTANT THAT
IDENTIFIED A NUMBER OF
DEFICIENCIES --
THAT EXISTED IN OUR PRISON
PRIMARILY DUE TO THE FACT THAT
THEY WEREN'T REPLACED.
DURING THE THAT RECOMMENDED
CYCLES ASSESSMENT YIELDED AN
AVERAGE RATING ACROSS OUR
PORTFOLIO OF 60%.
INDUSTRY STANDARD --
FOR FOR FACILITIES OF OUR TYPE
IS THAT IF YOU ACHIEVE A 65%
MORE OR MORE RATING --
THAT CAN THAT FACILITY CONDITION
IS KNOWN AS POOR ARE EXTREMELY
POOR AND WHAT THAT TELLS ME AS A
FACILITY --
MANAGER IS THAT I HAVE TO START
A PLANNING CYCLE THAT IDENTIFIES
HOW THAT FACILITY CAN BE
REPLACED OR SIGNIFICANTLY
REPAIRED SO CAN CONTINUE TO
OPERATE FOR ITS PURPOSE --
SO --
WITHOUT IN HAND IN TWENTY ELEVEN
WE STARTED TO SUBMIT AYE.
A SERIES OF PROPOSALS THAT WOULD
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE CONDITIONS
AND WE'VE BEEN FORTUNATE TO GET
A NUMBER OF A SUPPLEMENTAL
APPROACH APPROPRIATIONS ALONG
THE WAY --
BUT WHAT I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT
TODAY IS THE PLANNING PROCESS
THAT WE UNDERTAKEN WE DO THIS
WORK.
SO I'M PLANNING IS IT RUDE.
ITERATIVE.
I'M MORE ALWAYS IN THE PLANNING
STAGE -- WE
ARE ALWAYS OUT IN THE FIELD WE
SPEAKING --
TO CODE OFFICIALS ON WHAT
UPCOMING CODE CHANGES ARE IN
PLACE.
INTERACTING WITH REGULATORS ON
SOME OF THE OUR FACILITIES THAT
HAVE REGULATORY IMPLICATIONS.
AND SO WE'RE ALWAYS GATHERING
THAT INFORMATION.
I'M AND AT THE SAME TIME THAT
WE'RE GATHERING THE FIELD
INFORMATION ALSO SPEAKING TO
EXECUTIVES. TO MY COLLEAGUES
HERE TODAY CAPPING ALISON INJURY
BASCO ART TO KEY EXECUTIVES THAT
I WOULD SPEAK TO BECAUSE IN
ADDITION TO WHAT'S HAPPENING ON
THE GROUND.
THERE ARE THINGS THAT ARE
IMPACTING --
HOW WE OPERATE OUR FACILITIES
THERE ARE POLICY IMPLICATIONS
THERE ARE TRENDING INFORMATION?
MISSION CHANGES --
ALL OF THOSE THINGS ARE
IMPORTANT INPUT INTO THE
PLANNING PROCESS FOR WHAT SOUNDS
LIKE A SIMPLE --
FACILITY RELATED --
EXERCISE.
SO SO THE OTHER THING THAT WE
LOOK AT ONE WORD DOING THIS THIS
EFFORT IS WE LOOK AT WHERE OUR
ASSETS WHAT IS THE CONDITION OF
THESE ASSETS.
DO WE HAVE ANY DATA ON THE
ASSETS HOW ARE THEY OPERATING
FOR THE INTENDED PURPOSE --
WHAT ARE --
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE NEEDED TO
KEEP THAT ASSET OPERATING IN SO
AGAIN ALL OF THOSE --
INPUTS ARE IN PLACE I'M ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE LOOK AT IS IS
THERE AN OPPORTUNITY TO NOT JUST
LOOK AT STATE ON ASSETS BUT
CONSIDER OP PRIVATE OR OUTSIDE
ASSETS.
AND SOMETIMES THAT MAKES SENSE
BECAUSE THEY CAN --
DELIVERED TO US FASTER FOR
HAVING A POPULATION PRESSURE BUT
SOMETIMES IT JUST MAKES SENSE
BECAUSE THERE MIGHT BE A BETTER
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE THAT
POPULATION IN THE COMMUNITY AND
A SMALLER SETTING.
SO WE LOOK AT NOT ONLY HOW WE
PRIORITIZE ASSETS FOR STATE
OWNED BUT WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S
AN OFFRAMP. TO DELIVER THAT THE
NEEDED MISSION IN A DIFFERENT
FASHION.
SO THAT'LL SETS THE STAGE FOR
THE VERY FORMAL PROCESS WE CALL
THE CALL LETTER PROCESS.
WHERE WE SEEK --
EACH INSTITUTION TO SEND US A
DETAILED PROJECT --
SCOPE TO US WITH PRELIMINARY
COST ESTIMATES.
THOSE COME IN ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
AND THEN WE SIT DOWN WITH THE
EXECUTIVES OF THE DIFFERENT
OPERATING DIVISIONS.
AND WE GO THROUGH THEM AND THE
THE FACTORS WE USED TO DETERMINE
WHAT WOULD BE CONSIDERED A
PRIORITY PROJECT.
IS IT NECESSARY TO COMPLY WITH
STATUTORY AND REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS.
DOESN'T ADDRESS FIRE LIFE SAFETY
CONDITIONS IS IT NEEDED TO
ADDRESS THE COURT MANDATE.
IS IT NEEDED TO ADDRESS ACCESS
COMPLIANCE.
IS IT NECESSARY TO MAINTAIN
ONGOING OPERATIONS IN
PROGRAMMING HEALTH CARE HOUSING
SECTOR.
THE DISTINCTION BETWEEN THIS
LIST THAT WE'RE GATHERING
BETWEEN DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND
SPECIAL CARE AND CAPITAL OUTLAY.
IS THAT WE ALSO ASK IS THE
PROJECT THAT IS NECESSARY TO
IMPROVE UPON THOSE OPERATIONS SO
THAT.
IMPROVEMENT THAT BETTERMENT IF
YOU WILL IS TYPICALLY FALLS IN
THE CAPITAL OUTLAY DOCKET.
SO ONCE WE REACHED INTERNAL
CONSENSUS AS IT RELATES TO THE
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECT.
WE GATHER ABOUT TWENTY TO THIRTY
PROJECTS THAT WE BELIEVE ARE
NECESSARY TO BETTER THE
OPERATIONS --
THAT EXIST IN OUR PRISONS AND
THOSE ARE SUBMITTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE EACH YEAR.
I IN AUGUST OF EACH YEAR AND
DEPENDING ON HOW ON THEIR VIEW
OF OF THESE PROJECTS.
THERE ARE SUBMITTED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND IF
APPROVED BY THE LEGISLATURE WE
AND ACT UPON THEM.
I'M THE COMMITTEE HAS I BELIEVE
A SUMMARY OF THE CAPITAL OUTLAY
REQUEST AND I'D BE HAPPY.
TO SPEAK ABOUT THOSE PARTICULAR --
PROJECTS IF YOU'D LIKE
[inaudible]
I'M. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT YOU
ASKED FOR WAS THE TWELVE PRISON
STUDY THE UPDATE ON THE TWELVE
PRISON STUDY --
IF YOU DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE CAP OUT LIKE TO MOVE
ON TO THE TOP PRISON STUDY.
OKAY SO THE TWELVE PRISON STUDY --
IT'S IT'S IN A SENSE OF FOLLOW
ON TO THE INITIAL FACILITY
ASSESSMENT THAT WE DID IN TWENTY
ELEVEN IT'S A DEEPER DIVE A FEW
WELL.
IT'S TAKING --
THE A SERIOUS LOOK AT OUR TWELVE
OLDEST PRISONS KNOWING THAT THEY
WILL HAVE EXCEEDED THEIR USEFUL
LIFE MUCH FASTER THAN OUR NEW
PRISONS --
AND INDEED IF YOU'VE BEEN TO
SOME.
I'M.
BEFORE I GO INTO THAT --
TOLD PRISON STUDY I WANT --
TO BE CLEAR THAT.
WHEN PEOPLE CALL 206-7 WAS
ENACTED?
THE LEGISLATURE ASKED US TO
CONSIDER A NUMBER OF FACTORS IN
EVALUATING --
WHETHER OR NOT ARE FACILITY
RELATED REQUESTS --
WOULD BE CONSIDERED FOR FUNDING.
I THINK I OUTLINED FOR YOU THE
CRITERIA THAT THAT WE USE IN THE
PLANNING EFFORT TO DEVELOP THIS --
THIS APPROACH.
I WANNA GIVEN A COUPLE EXAMPLES
OF HOW WE VIEWS THE TWENTY SIXTY
SEVEN LANGUAGE.
I'M IN EARLIER IN THE DECADE
WHEN THE JUVENILE FACILITY
POPULATION WAS DECLINING WE DID
A SIMILAR ANALYSIS TO WHAT'S
BEING ASKED HIM --
TWENTY SIXTY SEVEN AND WE
DETERMINED THAT BASED ON THAT
ANALYSIS THAT WE COULD CLOSE --
SEVERAL JUVENILE FACILITIES.
AND WE LOOKED AT FACTORS THAT
WERE IMPORTANT IN JUVENILE
OPERATIONS ARE THEY IN
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY ARE --
WELL SERVED BY VOLUNTEERS.
ARE THEY IN COMMUNITIES WHERE HI
FOLKS COULD HIRE EFFECTIVELY --
WHAT IS THE VALUE OF THE ASSET
SPENCE NEEDED FOR THAT ASSN WE
USE THAT SAME PRIVATIZATION
PROCESS?
ON TO MAKE THOSE DETERMINATIONS
WE ALSO USE A SIMILAR PROCESS
WHEN WE EVALUATED A DECLINING
FEMALE POPULATION.
POPULATION WILL CONTINUE TO
DECLINE WE WE EVALUATED OUR
PRISONS AND DETERMINED WE COULD
CLOSE.
AND REPURPOSE --
THE VALLEY STATE PRISON AND AND
TURN IT INTO ADULTS BUT KNOWING
THAT THERE WAS A POPULATION
SHORTFALL WE OPENED A FEMALE
FACILITY IN FOLSOM.
AND WE DID THAT AGAIN WITH ALL
THAT CRITERION MIND --
FULSOME IS A GOOD LOCATION FOR
HIRING --
FEMALES --
AND AND IT'S A SMALLER FACILITY
SO SO IT'S WILL SERVICE.
THE NEED WE DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH
FOR THREE LARGE PRISONS WE WE
STILL HAD NEED MORE THAN TWO SO.
ON THE FULL SOME WOMEN'S
FACILITY GAVE US ENOUGH OF THE
OF THE BUFFER THERE.
I'M I'M.
A REAL KEY INDICATOR FOR US IS
THE POPULATION --
THAT WE SERVE SO WE LOOK AT A
FIVE YEAR HORIZON FOR IT FOR OUR
POPULATION AND THE REASON WHY WE
LOOK AT THE FIVE YEARS IS
BECAUSE IT TYPICALLY TAKES FIVE
YEARS FROM INCEPTION OF AN IDEA
OF A PROJECT.
TO ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTING ON THE
PROJECT SO IT'S AN IMPORTANT --
FACTOR FOR US AND WE ACTUALLY --
MAINTAIN WHAT'S CALLED A GAP
CHART IT'S IN THE A AND A MASTER
PLAN THE DEPARTMENT PUBLISHES.
AND THAT GOT CHART LAYS OUT
WHERE OUR POPULATION IS AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE FACTORS WE USE --
WHEN WE'RE DOING OUR PLANNING
EFFORT?
I'M SORRY I WANTED --
TO MAKE IT CLEAR TO YOU THAT
THAT'S IMPORTANT --
PIECE OF HOW WE'RE GOING TO BE
PLANNING THE FUTURE ALL THOSE
CRITERIA ARE IN FACT QUITE HERE
WE'RE LOOKING AT WE'RE JUST
GONNA BE MUCH MORE SPECIFIC AND
HOW WE INCLUDE THAT.
PLANNING EFFORTS IN THE FUTURE.
SO THE TOTAL PRISON STUDY AGAIN
OUR IS A DEEPER DIVE IN THE
CONTINUATION OF OUR FORMER
ASSESSMENTS.
AND WE'LL ASK THE CONSULTANT TO
DEVELOP A LIST OF PROJECTS THAT
WE NEED --
THAT WE BELIEVE WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO MAY AFFECT OF
OPERATIONS IN OUR PRISON.
I'M I'VE SEEN A COUPLE OF THOSE
EARLIER DRAFTS AND THOSE DROPS
INDICATE THAT IT'S GOING TO BE A
COMBINATION OF SPECIAL CARE AND
FOR MAINTENANCE PROJECTS BUT
ALSO CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS --
UNFORTUNATELY THEIR WORK HAS --
SUFFERED --
THEY HAVE I THINK THAT THEY
UNDERESTIMATED THE WORK EFFORT
THAT WOULD BE NEEDED TO DO THE
TWELVE PRISON STUDY.
ON THE EARLY DRAFTS THAT I'VE
SEEN WOULD PROVE LITTLE UTILITY
FOR US AS A DEPARTMENT IN
DETERMINING WHERE.
WE NEED TO INVEST OUR PRECIOUS
RESOURCES GOING FORWARD SO WE
SPENT A CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF
TIME WITH THEM WORKING ON AT ITS --
AND CHANGES TO THE DOCUMENT --
THEY'VE HAD ANY NUMBER OF ERRORS
FROM COST ESTIMATE ERRORS --
TO PROJECT TWO FALSE ASSUMPTIONS --
ON WHAT PROJECTS WOULD BE NEEDED --
TO PROCEED AND IT'S JUST BEEN A
PRODUCT THAT --
UNFORTUNATELY IS NOT READY FOR
PRIME TIME.
COMMENTS FROM LA L..
CAITLYN LA --
WE DIDN'T RAISE CONCERNS ON THIS
PROPOSAL OKAY WHAT ABOUT --
FINANCE.
OKAY ANY MEMBERS QUESTIONS.
YES MISTER.
TEN SO I I APOLOGIZE FOR WALKING
AND THEY SEE MY PRETTY COVER
THIS BUT CAN YOU CHANGES WALK
THROUGH WHY THE DELAY
[inaudible]
SO -- YOU
KNOW IT'S JUST A MYRIAD OF
FACTORS --
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THEY
NEEDED TO DO WAS TO USE CERTAIN
REFERENCE DOCUMENTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT.
AS AN EXAMPLE AND THEIR EFFORT --
I THINK THEY HAD A GREATER
EXPERT TAKE EXPECTATION OF THE
DEGREE OF DOCUMENTATION ON
BLUEPRINTS FOR THE OLDER PRISONS
THAT EXISTED --
THOSE ARE ABSOLUTELY KEY WHEN
THEY'RE TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S BURIED BENEATH WALLS AND
FLOORS --
AND WE SIMPLY DIDN'T HAVE THOSE
FOR SOME OF THE ESPECIALLY SOME
OF THE VERY OLD PRISONS --
AND SO THEY HAD TO SPEND A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF TIME TO
TRYIN --
UNDERSTAND THAT ON THEIR OWN --
THEY ALSO WE ALSO OF THE FORMER
SCA ASSESSMENT DONE BY AND
ANOTHER.
CONSULTANT AND I BELIEVE THAT
THEY THOUGHT THAT THAT WOULD
PROVE VALUABLE TO THEM BUT I
IT'S A NEXT IT WAS AN EXTENSIVE
AMOUNT OF DATA I DON'T THINK
THEY REALLY.
APPRECIATED UNDERSTOOD HOW THEY
COULD TRANSLATE THAT DAY IT DATA
INTO THEIR WORK EFFORT.
SO THOSE INITIAL REPORTS CAME IN --
WITH --
THINGS LIKE COULD NOT
UNDERSTANDING HOW TO APPLY THE
FCI INDEX IN A WAY THAT WOULD
INFORM US AS A PROPERTY OWNER --
WHERE SHOULD WE SHOULD INVEST
OUR MONIES?
SO FACILITY CONDITION INDEX OR
FCI IS A SORT OF A STANDARD A
METRIC USED BY COMMERCIAL --
OPERATORS INDUSTRIAL OPERATORS
EXCEPT TRUCK.
TO PUT A PEN IN AND I'M AN
AMOUNT TO AN IN A CONDITION.
OF YOUR YOUR FACILITY AND IT HAS
RANGES FROM.
POOR TO FAIR GOOD EXCELLENT AND
TYPICALLY IT'S DRIVEN BY THE
USEFUL LIFE OF THE PROPERTY.
IN OUR CASE --
WE HAVE A LOT OF BUILDINGS.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE A LOT
OF BURIED INFRASTRUCTURE SYSTEMS
THAT ARE WITHIN THOSE WALLS THAT
HAVE A SHORTER USEFUL LIFE.
SO -- I
THINK THAT MAYBE THAT WAS
PERHAPS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THEY STRUGGLED WITH THIS
UNDERSTANDING THAT.
THEY ALSO STRUGGLED WITH
SUBMITTING TO US PROJECTS THAT
JUST BECAUSE THEY EXCEEDED THEIR
USEFUL LIFE THEY PRESENTED THEM
AS PROJECTS THAT WE SHOULD
PROCEED WITH.
BUT WE WE WANTED TO TAKE A
DEEPER DIVE IN THAT AND LOOK AT
JUST BECAUSE SOMETHING IS IT
EXCEEDED IS YOU ITS USEFUL LIFE.
IS IT INDEED OPERATING IN A
DECENT CONDITION CAN WE RELIABLY
COUNT ON THAT PARTICULAR
FACILITY OR SYSTEM TO CONTINUE
TO OPERATE IN THAT FASHION.
AND SO WE'VE.
LOOKED AT REDUCING SOME OF THE
PROJECTS THAT THEY BELIEVE WERE
NECESSARY SIMPLY BECAUSE A LIFE
AND IT'S JUST A NUMBER.
YOU KNOW IT SOME OF OUR
FACILITIES OUR SERVER OLDER
FACILITIES LOOK --
ACTUALLY BETTER THAN SOME OF OUR
NEWER OFFICES.
SO IT'S A NUMBER BUT IT'S IT'S A
IT'S A GUIDE IF YOU WELL IT'S
NOT A HARD AND FAST --
NUMBER TWO FOR US TO REALIZE.
WHAT WHAT'S TYPICAL USEFUL LIFE
FOR THE EXTERIOR AND AN INTERNET
FOR FIFTY TO FIFTY FIVE YEARS
FOR AN END TO WHAT THEY CALL
INDUSTRIAL GRADE BUILDING IF IF
IT WAS A TYPICAL OFFICE BUILDING
YOU'RE IN THE THIRTY YEAR RANGE?
BUT THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS
WE AS AS ASSET OWNERS DON'T
DEMOLISH A THIRTY YEAR OLD
BUILDING.
YOU KNOW WE FIGURE OUT HOW --
TO CAN BECAUSE THE STRUCTURES
YOU KNOW ARE ARE FAIRLY --
IN FAIRLY GOOD SHAPE IT'S THE
SYSTEMS THAT FEED INTO IT THAT.
THAT REALLY START TO SUFFER AGE
SEE SAID FIFTY TO FIFTY FIVE
YEARS FOR THE EXTERIOR.
WHAT ABOUT THE INTERIOR --
WELL WERE UNIQUE IN THAT WE TEND
TO SUFFER --
EXTREME WEAR AND TEAR.
ALMOST ABUSE IF YOU WILL --
AND SO WHERE IT'S THE WHERE IT'S
AN AREA THAT HAS A LOT OF LOT OF
SYSTEMS THAT ARE TOUCHABLE LIKE
KITCHENS --
THOSE TEND TO HAVE A LOT MORE
WEAR AND TEAR.
WE HAVE PRETTY STURDY STRUCTURE
SO A LOT OF CONCRETE WALLS
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO DO MUCH
DAMAGE TO THE GIVES YOUR
ESTIMATE FORMER [inaudible]
I'M.
I WOULD SAY IT'S PROBABLY IN THE
SAME VEIN THE INTERIOR
STRUCTURES.
ARE IN THE SAME VEIN SYSTEMS ARE
MORE IN THE TWENTY TO THIRTY
THIRTY YEAR RANGE.
LIKE WATER SYSTEMS YEAH OUR
SYSTEM YEAH.
THE SOUL ON THIS REPORT WAS BE
COMPLETED FALL OF EIGHTEEN THE
SUMMER OF NINETEEN NOW WOULD NOT
THE DATE IS.
JUNE TWENTIETH OF TWENTY TWENTY
NO NO NO NO IT IT WE'RE STILL
PLANNING ISSUE YEAH WE STILL
WANTED DOING THINGS HERE IT IS A
REASON WHY CAN'T BE DONE BEFORE
THE FOR THE BUDGET PROCESS IS
COMPLETED.
YEAH I THINK WE WE CAN CERTAINLY
LOOK AT THAT --
YOU KNOW I I WANNA MAKE SURE
IT'S A DOCUMENT THAT WE ARE
CONFIDENT --
DOESN'T HAVE A LOT OF OF IS THAT
THAT HAVEN'T BEEN ADDRESSED IT I
THINK WE'RE CLOSE ON THE RIDGE.
WE USE THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
FACILITY AS IT AS A TEMPLATE A
FORMAT IF YOU WILL SO LET'S
FIGURE OUT HOW TO WRITE IT UP
FOR ONE FACILITY.
AND THEN MOVE FORWARD --
AND USE THAT SAME FORMATFOR THE
OTHERS IN HINDSIGHT THAT WAS
PROBABLY NOT THE BEST CHOICE
BECAUSE IT'S SO COMPLEX AS A
MAJOR REASON WHY THEY CAN'T BE
DONE BEFORE MAY FIFTEENTH.
I'M OR WHAT IS THE REASON I
CAN'T GET THEM FROM THE TWELVE
SO REMEMBER SO THEY ARE BEING
PRODUCED IN INDIVIDUAL CHAPTERS
TO EACH PERSON HAS ITS OWN
CHAPTER.
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL FACILITY IS
CURRENTLY UNDER REVIEW BY THE
EXECUTIVE BODY SO THAT'S THE
FEDERAL RECEIVER'S OFFICE AND
THE UNDERSECRETARIES AND THE
DIRECTORS --
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
CONSISTENT WITH THEIR MISSION
AND THEIR GOALS. FOR THE ASSET.
I'M IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THE CMS
SO THAT YOU CAN GET A FLAVOR FOR
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT WE MIGHT BE ABLE
TO CIRCULATE THE EARLIER I'D
HAVE TO CHECK WITH STAFF TO MAKE
SURE.
BUT THEN EACH ONE THAT FOLLOWS
IS IS FOLLOWING ON A FASTER PATH
BECAUSE THE FORMAT WAS REALLY
THE STRUGGLE TO GET THAT SO SURE
THAT MAKES SENSE.
IT NEEDS TO BE PROVIDED IN A
FORMAT THAT THE GENERAL PUBLIC
WHO'S NOT A FACILITY PLANT
PERSON CAN UNDERSTAND AND SO
THAT'S BEEN OUR FEEDBACK TO IT.
THE REPORT IT'S A VERY TECHNICAL
SHE'S A LOT OF ABBREVIATIONS AND
YOU'RE TRYING TO WHAT WAS THAT
AGAIN YOU'RE GOING BACK AND
LOOKING FOR IT SO IF THAT WAS
ONE OF OUR RECOMMENDATIONS GOING
FORWARD IS.
TO HAVE IT WRITTEN IN A FASHION
THAT THIS PERSON COULD
UNDERSTAND IT.
THIS SALUTE THE SUPPORT HOW DO
YOU DEVELOP YOUR CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENT PRIORITIES.
WHEN YOU HAVE AND FINISH THIS
REPORT BECAUSE THERE AREN'T
REQUEST THE COMMAND?
THAT WERE BEING ASKED TO FUND SO
I THINK OUR OUR CHALLENGES IS.
WITHOUT A LIST OF PRIORITIES OR
WITHOUT A METHODOLOGY.
THE REQUEST KEEP COMING IN THAT
THERE'S NO OVERALL STUDIES SO
HOW WOULD YOU WHAT.
WHY WOULD WHY WOULD WE OR WHY
SHOULD WE --
INVEST MONEY WITHOUT THIS REPORT
BEING DONE.
I CAN APPRECIATE THE HESITATION
THE CONCERN --
WE ARE I'M NOT SURE WHEN YOU
JOINED IN MY EARLIER
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW WE
PRIORITIZE AND AND IT'SACTUALLY
VERY CONSISTENT WITH THE TENANTS
OF OF THE PENAL CODE.
TWENTY SIXTY SEVEN I'M.
IT IT'S OUR BELIEF THAT THE
PROJECTS THAT WERE SUBMITTING.
TODAY THE CAPITAL PROJECTS IN
THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS ARE ALL CRITICAL
PROJECTS.
WE BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE
ABSOLUTELY NO IN SIN CAFFEINE'S
HERE TO SPEAK TO SOME OF THE
IMPACTS.
ON THESE THESE PROJECTS HAVE ON
HER --
OPERATING CONDITIONS THERE ISN'T
A PROJECT THAT WE'RE SUBMITTING
HERE TODAY THAT.
IS NOT SOMETHING THAT WE
WOULDN'T CONSIDER --
FOR THE TWELVE PRISONS IN FACT
IN LOOKING AT THE FEW --
THAT I'VE READ SO FAR --
A NUMBER OF THE PROJECTS ARE
ALREADY IN THE THE TOLD PRISON
CITY SO THEY'RE IDENTIFIED THE
SAME THING WE'RE IDENTIFYING --
AT AND YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT WE
DON'T HAVE ANY REGRETS FOR
MAKING THESE REQUESTS AND IN
TURN MAKING HIS INVESTMENTS AND
I CAN SAY I HAVE NO REGRETS
BECAUSE THEY SEE THESE
CONDITIONS I SEE THE IMPACT TO
THE TO THE PRISONS IF WE WAIT.
ANY LONGER --
THE WAY CONSTRUCTION COSTS WERE
THE PRICES SIMPLY GO OUT.
SO I I THINK THAT THE PROJECTS
WERE SUBMITTING HERE TODAY ARE
NOT PROJECTS THAT WE WOULDN'T --
WE WILL WE BELIEVE OUR WOULDN'T
BE NECESSARY IN THIS TWELVE
PERSON STUDY --
I MEAN I'M I'M PRETTY CONFIDENT
IN SAYING THAT HERE TODAY BUT
KNOWING THAT WE HAVE FINING
POPULATION I I CAN APPRECIATE
YOUR CONCERN AND WHETHER OR NOT
WE'RE MAKING INVESTMENTS IN THE
RIGHT FACILITIES --
GOING FORWARD.
WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS THAT --
THE REPORT WILL HIGHLIGHT BUT
IT'S OBVIOUS WE HAVE LEAKING
ROOFS INTO CELLS AND TODAY ROOMS
AND CLASSROOMS I HAVE TO WE HAVE
TO SHUT DOWN CLASSROOMS ON A
REGULAR BASIS.
WE HAVE WE HAVE ONE INSTITUTION
THAT'S BEEN DOWN FROM THIS TWO
YEARS.
SO YOU'RE NOT PROVIDING AN
ADEQUATE EDUCATION.
NOW WITH FIFTY SEVEN THAT QUIT
CELEBRITY AND SO TO HE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERN YEAH WE WE
WE AGREE WE SHARE THE SAME
CONCERN AND I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
WERE HERE.
LAST YEAR SELECT GROUNDHOG DAY
AGAIN I MEAN SECRETARY KERN AND
CAME BEFORE THE COMMITTEE AND
YOU KNOW I HAD REQUESTED.
A REPORT A PRIORITIZATION OF ALL
THE DIFFERENT FACILITIES --
A YEAR LATER WE STILL HAVEN'T.
SO -- THAT
WAS FOR THE CONDITION UPON US
DOING APPROPRIATIONS.
SO.
THE WORDS TRUST US IT DOESN'T.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
RIGHT I MEAN YOU'RE NOT ASKING
FOR LUNCH MONEY RIGHT NOW YOU'RE
ASKING FOR YOU KNOW ALMOST A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE COSTS WHEN.
WE'RE NOT SAYING THAT IT'S NOT
CRITICAL BUT THE THE THE THING
IN BUDGET COMMITTEES
EVERYTHING'S CRITICAL.
IF YOU GO TO A YOU KNOW RIGHT
RIGHT NEXT DOOR IS ALL THE
HOMELESS AS A MENTAL HEALTH --
DISCUSSION THAT'S CRITICAL SO
EVERYTHING IS ACTUALLY CRITICAL
SO.
WE HAVE.
TO DO A JOB SCHERING THAT OUR
MONEY IS REALLY FAST SPENT.
INTO SAYING HEY TRUST US.
THE REPORTS NOT DONE.
EVERYTHING'S OKAY.
WE JUST NEED THE MONEY BECAUSE
IT'S CRITICAL.
THAT TO SOME OF THE PASS MUSTER
SO I THINK --
AGAIN I THINK WHAT YOU'VE
PRESENTED TODAY --
DOESN'T FILLED THE REQUEST I
MADE A YEAR AGO --
DURING SUCH TIME THAT.
THE REQUEST WAS IMPOSSIBLE TO
FOR FELT THAT SHOULD AND
COMMUNICATED TO MY OFFICE TO
THIS COMMITTEE IT WASN'T.
SO -- INTEL
THE DEPARTMENT CAN BRING FORWARD
A BROADER PLAN.
A BROADER VISION.
OF WHERE THEY WANT TO SPEND THE
MONEY.
AND WHAT ARE THE PRIORITIES FOR
SAYS HEY HERE'S YOU KNOW THE
BRUCE LEE CUSTOM WE NEED MONEY.
THAT'S THAT'S NOT AN ADEQUATE --
ANSWER IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
BUDGET.
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
THINGS MUCH MORE GLOBAL THE AND
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THINGS MORE
LONG TERM.
SO -- AGAIN.
THE REQUESTED STILL STANDING
FROM TWELVE MONTHS AGO THIS
WASN'T A NEW WASN'T.
LAST WEEK OR TWO WEEKS AGO THIS
IS.
A YEAR AGO SECRETARY PROMISED
THAT THEY WOULD GET THIS DONE
AHEAD FALL CONVERSATIONS WITH
HIM IN HIS TEAM. TO THIS DAY
HAVEN'T RECEIVED ANYTHING.
SO IT COULD HAVE BEEN LOST IN
EMAIL OR MAYBE WENT TO SPAM --
SO IF THAT'S THE CASE THEN.
HAPPY TO YOU KNOW IT'S ON ME.
HOW?
HOW THE COMMITTEE CAN EVALUATE?
THESE PROPOSALS BECAUSE OF THE
DEPARTMENTS [inaudible]
TRACK RECORD.
AN IMPLEMENT IMPLEMENTATION AND
THE DIRECT THE DEPARTMENT'S LACK
OF VISION.
AND FRANKLY LIKE PLAN.
SO IF IF THE YOU KNOW THE THE
DEPARTMENT DOESN'T FOR PHIL I
REQUEST IT MAKES IT VERY
DIFFICULT FOR US. TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE THESE THINGS.
IT'S A FAIR ENOUGH AND YOU KNOW
I CONSIDER MYSELF AN ADVOCATE --
FOR ALL THE OPERATIONS THAT
EXIST IN THE PRISON.
AND I DON'T WANT THE FAILURE OF
MY ABILITY TO COMPLETE THIS
REPORT TIMING TO NEGATIVELY
IMPACT --
THE CONDITIONS THAT EXIST OUT
THERE SO I'M GONNA DOUBLE BACK
WITH STAFF TO SEE WHAT THINGS.
MIGHT BE ABLE TO BE SHARED --
PERHAPS EVEN ON A FLOW BASIS --
THAT COULD HELP GET YOU MORE
COME DO INDEED HAVE A PLANNING
PROCESS.
SO I THINK JUST RESTATE I THINK
WHAT.
WHAT AT LEAST I'M NOT JUST
SPEAKING FOR MYSELF?
WHAT WHAT I WAS LOOKING FOR IS?
A LIST OF A LIST OF PRIORITIES.
BY THE THIRTY FOUR FACILITIES
WHICH YOU KNOW WHAT IS THE
AMOUNT OF DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
AND YOU TO THESE FACILITIES
RIGHT BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT'S
CALM AS ALWAYS FIX THIS ROOF BUT
REALLY THERE'S ALL THIS STUFF
DOWN THE ROAD HERE.
SO SO THIS MAY BE TO THE
EMERGENCY DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
WHAT'S THE TOTAL DEPARTMENT.
BECAUSE WE WERE IN CHARGE OF
MAKING SURE WE'RE MAKING THE
RIGHT INVESTMENTS NOT JUST.
MAKING SURE THE ROOF IS FIXED.
SO.
WHAT'S YOU KNOW WHAT THE TOTAL
COST FOR ALL THREE FOUR BUT THE
PRIORITY FOR ALL THIRTY FOUR
WHAT IS.
THE A PRIORITY OF THE DEPARTMENT
BASED ON BASED ON YOUR VIEW IN
IRAQ AND WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT
ASKING. FOR YOU KNOW. FOR YOU TO
AGREE WITH THE POWER LESS I
DON'T HAVE A PART OF THIS I'M
REALLY LOOKING FOR WHAT IS YOUR
PRIORITY LIST SO THAT WE CAN.
EVALUATE IT BASED ON WHAT YOU'RE
PRESENTING TO US BECAUSE YOU
KNOW IF YOU PLAY IF YOU ASKING
FOR YOU KNOW --
MONEY TO DO DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
FOR TEN FACILITIES BUT THE OTHER
ONES ARE BIGGER PARTIES OR THAT
BIGGER.
PRICE TAG SO OFTEN.
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHY WE'RE DOING
THIS RIGHT SO BUT WE CAN'T WE
DON'T HAVE THAT.
SO -- AGAIN
REALLY REALLY --
HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
ONGOING.
DISCUSSION I DON'T THINK THIS
NEEDS TO BE THE END OF THE
DISCUSSION THIS YEAR I THINK WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS.
AND TO CONTINUE TO REFINE THAT
BUT THERE IS SOME OF WHAT.
THERE'S A LOT OF LOOPHOLES HERE.
BECAUSE THAT OTHERWISETHEN WE
MIGHT AS WELL.
JUST FLIP THE POINT THAT WE CAN
JUST KIND OF RANDOMLY SELECT.
WORK IS FINDING WHAT DOESN'T BUT
THAT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE A VERY
JUDICIOUS APPROACH [inaudible]
TO FUNDING.
SO THE EASIER APPROACH WOULD
JUST BE TO NOT FIND ANY OF IT.
AND TO SAY WELL WHEN YOU'RE
READY TO PRESENT.
THE INFORMATION IN A FASHION
THAT -- YOU
KNOW IS IS UNDERSTANDABLE THEN
WE COULD.
MOVE FORWARD BUT THESE ARE
FAIRLY THE DECK NOT NONE OF
THESE ARE SMALL NUMBERS THESE
ARE NOT LIKE FIFTY THOUSAND OR
TEN THOUSAND THESE ARE ALL VERY.
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF MONEY
WITH NOT A LOT OF OVERALL BACK.
I WILL SAY THAT OUR
DETERIORATION OF OUR PHYSICAL
PLANT WITHIN OUR PRISONS THE
CERTAINLY BEEN.
USE OF GREAT CONCERN FOR THOSE
WHO TRYING TO MANAGE --
THESE FACILITIES WITH PLASTIC
BAGS DEFERRED IN WATER TO A
TRASH CAN.
AND DEALING WITH FIRES THAT FAR.
FAILED AND THE FIRE MARSHAL.
SHUT US DOWN FROM OPERATING --
SO WE HAVE TO COME UP WITH AN
ALTERNATIVE PLAN ON HOW TO
PREPARE FOOD WHICH COSTS EVEN
MORE MONEY.
THAN IT WOULD IN A REGULAR
KITCHEN SO ALL OF IT IT'S IT'S
VERY VERY COMPLEX AND AND IT
CERTAINLY --
NOT LOST ON US OF HOW EXTREME
THE PROBLEM IS --
AND OF COURSE THERE WAS THE
EXPERT HERE AS FAR AS THE ACTUAL
COST OF ALL OF THAT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BEEN TOTALED UP
THESE WERE THE PRIORITY FOR THIS
YEAR BASED ON BASED ON WHAT WE
AND I THINK IT CAME FROM A LIST
WE DO HAVE LISTS OF BILLIONS
DOLLARS.
WORTH OF PROJECTS AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE OF THINGS THAT COULD BE
DONE.
THAT'S A LETTER ASKING FOR THEM
NO I I MEAN THAT'S THE MAIN.
I'M NOT ASKING FOR IT YOU KNOW
THOUSAND LINES STRETCHED OUT
THOUGH I MEAN I'M I LIKE THAT
THAT MY TRUCK MY COLLEAGUES
CRAZY -- SO
WOULD NOT DOTHAT TO THEM BUT I
MEAN.
WHAT I MEAN WHEN YOU DEVELOP
THESE PRIORITIES HOW HOW DO YOU
DO AND YOU MUST HAVE A PROCESS
FOR DOING IT AND?
SAY HEY DID THIS IS WHAT'S GOING
TO THE TOP AND SO IF THERE'S A
METHODOLOGY.
LET US KNOW WHAT IT IS IN A
WE'RE NOT ME AGAIN WHAT I'M
ASKING YOU. TO I I I BELIEVE I
THINK YOU WERE ASKING FOR A
CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF HOW YOU
GOT TO WHERE YOU'RE GOING AND
THEN ALSO WHERE YOU'RE GOING.
IT'S FOR AND THAT'S NOT AND
THAT'S MISSING ALL ALL WE'RE
SAYING IS THE FINAL.
RESULT I THINK YOU HAVE TO YOU
HAVE TO SHOW THE COMMITTEE
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE BLACK BOX.
BECAUSE THEN WE GET TO DETERMINE
WHETHER WE AGREE WITH THAT.
DECISION MAKE IT OR NOT.
SO.
AGAIN THE HOPE IS THAT WE CAN
KEEP YOU KNOW WORK TOGETHER
RIGHT RIGHT.
RIGHT I KNOW IT'S KIND OF INCOME
IN THE BUILDING.
THE TO WORK TOGETHER AND TRY TO
AGAIN COME TO SOME SORT OF
RESOLUTION BEFORE.
YOU KNOW BEFORE ME.
OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS YES
MISTER JONES SAWYER AND OUT TO
MAKE A BRIEF OF IT PROFIT TO SO
WILL HELP--
YOU GET THERE --
IN MY PREVIOUS LIFE I WAS
DIRECTOR REAL ESTATE FOR THE
CITY OF LA.
AND I DEALT WITH DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE OF FOUR THOUSAND
CITY BUILDING FROM CITY HALL THE
RE DOWN TO AN OUTHOUSE.
AND IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT
[inaudible] TO LET ELECTED
OFFICIALS NOW.
THAT YOU NEED MONEY FOR
SOMETHING OTHER WE CAN'T SEE OR
DON'T UNDERSTAND.
OR WE DON'T MAKE CLEAR TIMES A
LOT OF TIMES I DID MAKE CLEAR
THE URGENCY.
OF THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS A LEAKY
ROOF.
WELL.
CAUSE DAMAGE TO COMPUTERS
WASTING CAUSE DAMAGE TO THE
FLOOR WHICH THEN CAUSES WATER
DAMAGE DUE TO SPEAK SECOND FLOOR
DOWN TO THE FIRST FLOOR.
SOMETIMES YOU'VE GOT TO GO
THROUGH THAT OR EVEN WHEN YOU DO
YOUR CALCULATIONS I HAVE A RULE
OF THUMB THAT WHENEVER I SEE
NUMBERS.
WITH THE FIVE A MORE ZEROS.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S A REAL
NUMBERS THOSE ARE MADE UP
NUMBERS DOES A SWAG IS JUST.
AND JUST AS SOME ZEROS TO IT.
GET IN ABOUT AROUND ABOUT.
NUMBER WHAT GENERALLY HAPPENS IS
YOU START A PROJECT AND THEN YOU
BACK IN HERE IN THIS COMMITTEE
ASKING FOR MORE MONEY BECAUSE
YOU DID ASK FOR ENOUGH.
OR WASN'T SPECIFIC ENOUGH TO GET
IT DOWN.
SO THAT YOU --
ACTUALLY NEW.
WHAT YOU NEED TO TAKE TO GET
THAT NUMBER AND SOMETIMES WE GO
BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN A
BONELESS PRIVATE SECTORS?
NUMBER AND GOVERNMENT NUMBERS OF
OR NOT. FOR A LOT MORE AS MUCH
WE GET WERE RETICENT AND PUTTING
IN A BIGGER NUMBER.
ALL WE REALLY NEED A BIGGER
NUMBER SO I WANT TO OFFER THE
SAME SET I'M PROBABLY THE ONE I
WANT TO GET INTO MINUTIA BECAUSE
I ALSO AND MAKE SURE IT GETS
DONE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY.
IF WE WERE TO GIVE YOU THIS
MONEY AND SOME OF US ARE HERE
FOR ANOTHER HOPEFULLY SIX MMHM
MORE YEARS WE DON'T WANNA BE
HERE FOUR YEARS FROM NOW AND
YOU'RE IN HERE SAYING YOU KNOW
WHAT.
WE CAN GET THIS DONE WE NEED
ANOTHER TWO MILLION ANOTHER ONE
MILLION OTHER.
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE HERE.
FOR THE BUDGET CHAIR.
I'VE ASKED FOR THINGS AND YOU
FEEL LIKE YOU'RE BEING PUT OFF
WHAT WHICH WEALTHIER MEMBERS YOU
CAN'T DO THAT HE USED TO DO IT
NOT YOU DID IT IF YOU CAN'T DO
THAT THE WAY THEY USED TO DO
WITH. SIX YEAR MEMBERS WE
ACTUALLY ARE LISTENING ACTUALLY
WANT TO KNOW SO.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW HOW YOU
CAME UP WITH THE ESTIMATES IF
IT'S A PRIVATE SECTOR.
ESTIMATOR PRESIDENT TERM BECAUSE
WHEN YOU HANDED OFF THE WORK TO
YOUR IN.
AN INTERNAL AS OPPOSED TO AN
OUTSIDE CONTRACTOR.
YOU CAN GET.
VARYING DEGREES OF NUMBERS AND
IN RUGBY OUT QUITE HONEST WITH
YOU --
PROFESSIONALISM AND GETTING THE
JOB DONE AND GET A JOB JOB DONE
RIGHT.
IN PRISONS WE DON'T HAVE THE
LUXURY OF MAKING A MISTAKE OR
NOT GETTING IT CORRECT.
AND SO I WOULD.
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH YOU ON
TRYING.
TO PUT THIS BOIL THIS DOWN SO
THAT.
SADDAM VALLEY THAT I UNDERSTAND
WHY.
THIS IS NEEDED NOT ONLY TO
PRIORITIZE IT BUT ALSO TO GIVE A
CLEAR UNDERSTANDING.
TO ANYONE I READ THESE REPORTS
THAT -- DELI
DEBT IS NECESSARY BUT THIS IS
WHY DISNEY'S GO FIRST SECOND
THIRD FOURTH I'M I'M ALSO
OFFERING --
DE TO HELP WITH THAT.
THANK YOU --
I'M GLAD YOU UNDERSTAND SO
THINGS IN PART OF YOUR
DESCRIPTION IS EXACTLY WHY WE'RE
STILL STRUGGLING TO GET THIS
CONSULTANT SUPPORT --
TO BE REALISTIC REPORT WE DID WE
WANTED AN OUTSIDE CONSULTORES
THAT IS IT IS OR NOT --
YOU HIGHER THAN THE GENERAL
SERVICES ENGINEER HIRE THEM I
MEAN I WE WANT TO GET WE HAD A
YEAH.
THE COMPETITIVE PROCESS WE WE
PICK SOMEONE THAT HAD FAMILIAR
WITH OUR PRISONS WE PICKED AN
ARCHITECTURAL FIRM THAT WOULD
HELP SERVE THEM IN THEIR
CAPACITY AS THE CONSULTANT THAT
ALSO HAD FAMILIARITY.
BUT THAT DIDN'T.
UNFORTUNATE DIDN'T YIELD A
PRODUCT THAT WE FELT THAT IT
BENEFITTED FROM THE WISDOM OF
ALL THE YEARS SERVING US --
AND SO WE ENDED UP WITH PROJECTS
THAT.
FRANKLY I DON'T THINK I COME
BEFORE YOU TWO YEARS FROM NOW
AND AND ASKED FOR A FUNDING FOR
ONE A COUPLE OF THESE PROJECTS
THAT ARE IN THIS REPORT.
BECAUSE THEY JUST WEREN'T
THOUGHT THROUGH.
I WANTED THINGS WE DID WILL BE A
BUILDING POLICE STATION FIRE
STATIONS LIBRARIES --
WE STOP IN THIS IS NO SLIGHT
CLUB I'M SORRY I'M LATE I GOT
HERE SO I DON'T KNOW YOUR
PROFESSIONAL.
EXPERTISE BUT WE STOP HAVING A
POLICE STATION.
BECAUSE THEY WOULD HAVE AN
OFFICE THE SIZES ROOM.
OFFICE AND THEN YOU HAVE POLICE
OFFICERS IN LITTLE BITTY CUBBY
HOLES AND YOU GO TO ANOTHER ONE
HE DOUBLE SMALL OFFICE AND BIG
GIGANTIC SERGEANTS DESK.
SO.
WE HAD TO HAVE SOME CONFORMITY
ALONG.
THE SLIME BUT WE ALSO LEARNED
THAT WHEN YOU GIVE IT --
TO TO STRUCTURE AND USE OF
ENGINEERS IN THE DAY WILL DRILL
DOWN AND MAKE SURE --
YOU GET IT DONE ON TIME AND ON
BUDGET CA THAT'S THAT'S REALLY
KIND OF MY CONCERN.
THAT WHATEVER WE DO WE GET IT
DONE ON TIME ABOUT.
MY LOOK FOR IT HAVING A
CONVERSATION WITH ME ON OKAY
THANK YOU --
ONE QUICK QUESTION ARE WE STILL
WE STILL USING THE SAME
CONSULTANT THAT DELAYED --
YES -- YOU
KNOW THEY WERE SO DEEP INTO IT
AND AND REALLY SO MUCH OF THE
WORK THAT WAS NECESSARY TO
PERFORM THIS TO PUT TOGETHER
SUPPORT WAS IN THE GATHERING AND
THE INTERPRETING OF DATA.
IT DIDN'T MAKE SENSE TO SWITCH
THEM OUT AT THAT POINT BUT WE
ARE HANDS ON WITH THIS CONSUMER
SPENDING AN INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF
TIME. TO GET THEM TO PRODUCE A
REPORT --
THAT MAKES SENSE FOR US CAN WORK
WE HAVE AN INCREASE THE BUDGET
FOR THE CONSULTANT NOW AND WE
MADE IT CLEAR TO THEM THAT THEY
YOU KNOW THE SKIT WE HAVE NOT
CHANGED THE SCOPE --
AND WE MADE CLEAR TO THEM THAT
WE EXPECT THAT THEY PROVIDE
PROVIDE ALL OF THE DELIVERABLES
THAT WE ASK FOR IN THAT SCOPE
AND THE MONEY IS OF THE MONEY
THAT WE AGREED UPON WHEN WE
SIGNED THE CONTRACT.
I WE CALCULATE THE AMOUNT OF
TIME THAT WE'VE SPENT ON IT THAT
WE NORMALLY WOULD NOT OF SPENT
ON IT IF IT HADN'T BEEN DONE
CORRECTLY.
NO YOU KNOW BUT I TELL YOU I'VE
NEVER CENTER SO WHICH AND WE'D
EXPECTED SIMPLY BECAUSE THE
STAFF.
IS CONSUMING SO MUCH TIME AND
WORKING WITH THEM IT'S A
LEGITIMATE QUESTION AND I WOULD
SAY I HAVEN'T SPENT SO MUCH TIME
IN MY STOP HAVING SPENT SO MUCH
TIME PERFECTING A CONSULTANT'S
REPORT.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY WE
WANT TO REPORT THAT I CAN GO TO
MY STAKEHOLDERS AND SAY WE'VE
GOT A PROJECT FOR YOU AND I AND
I IN IN DOING THAT I CAN'T JUST.
HAND OVER UP A REPORT THAT --
THE DAY RIGHT RIGHT.
OKAY -- WITH
THIS ITEM WILL BE HELD OVER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BEFORE WE GO
ANY FURTHER WE NEED TO TAKE THE
ROLE AND BECAUSE I KNOW SOME OF
YOU HAVE OTHER COMMITTEE
MEETINGS.
I WANT TO DO THAT AND WE ALSO
WANT TO DO IN THE VOTE ON WEBER
HERE JONES SAWYER HERE LACKEY
HERE MELENDEZ.
STONE.
OKAY FINE WE HAVE A QUORUM NOW
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO THE
TOP OF THE AGENDA SO THOSE OF
YOU WHO WAITING.
PATIENTLY --
FOR THE NEXT ITEM SHOULDN'T TAKE
VERY LONG WITH VOTE ITEM --
ONLY ISSUE NUMBER ONE VARYING
THERE IS CONTINUOUS SUSTAINABLE
ARMORY.
OF RENOVATION PROPOSAL THIS IS A
CALIFORNIA MILITARY DEPARTMENT.
PROPOSAL SO --
WAS THERE MOTION.
WHEN WILL THE SECOND SECOND OKAY --
ANY DISCUSSION ROLL CALL WEBER I
JONES SAWYER.
KEY HI MELENDEZ STONE.
THAT'S OUT OF FOR VOTE THANK YOU.
ISSUE NUMBER TO VOTE ON THE
ISSUE STATEWIDE ADVANCED PLANS
AND STUDIES --
STATEWIDE ADVANCED PLANS AND
STUDIES THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION THREE IN A THOUSAND
SKEWS ME GENERAL FUND. FOR
ARCHITECTURAL ENGINEERING
SERVICES THAT.
IT'S MOVED SECOND SECOND OKAY
ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER
BY LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
OKAY BRINGS TO THE LAST ITEM FOR
VOTE ONLY IS ISSUE NUMBER THREE
FACILITIES AND INFRASTRUCTURE
MAINTENANCE --
PROGRAM EXPANSION --
IS THERE MOTION.
SO MODE SO BACK IN A SECOND OKAY
ANY COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
ROLL CALL WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
ALL OF THOSE OUT ON A FOR VOTE
WILL HOLD IT OPEN --
FOR MELENDEZ TO VOTE IF SHE
COMES BEFORE THE END OF THE
MEETING OUR THAT BRINGS US NOW
TO THE SECOND ITEM FOR
DISCUSSION.
WHICH IS DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
OVERVIEW DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
BUDGET PROPOSAL AND PRISON
MAINTENANCE FUNDING METHODOLOGY
BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT IS CORRECT
THE ISSUE REALLY INVOLVES TWO
SEPARATE BUDGET REQUESTS TO A
REQUEST FOR A ONE TIME INCREASE
OF TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR
SPECIAL PAIRS AND DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS.
ARE FOR PROJECTS AROUND THE
STATE AT OUR FACILITIES.
THE SECOND REQUEST IS EIGHTEEN
POINT FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND
IN NINETEEN TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN
POINT ONE MILLION IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND FIFTY FIVE
POINT SIX MILLION ON MAINTENANCE
FUNDING.
AND AS PART OF THE PROPOSAL WERE
ASKING TO REPLACE OUR EXISTING
METHODOLOGY WHICH IS BASED ON A
PER PRISONER BASIS. TWO ONE THAT
IS BASED ON SQUARE FOOTAGE FOR
MAINTENANCE.
AGAIN WE HAVE THE SAME PANELISTS
FROM THE FIRST ISSUE ON THIS BUT
WE'LL KEEP IT BRIEF THANK YOU --
SO AGAIN --
THE PRIORITIZATION PROCESS WE
DEVELOPED FOR THE CAP ALLEY IS
IDENTICAL TO THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
EXCEPT THAT IT'S FOCUSES MORE
ACUTELY ON EXISTING CONDITIONS --
THAT HAVE BEEN DEFERRED BECAUSE
OF LACK OF FUNDING ACCENTURE.
I'M THE DEPARTMENT RECEIVES
TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS EACH
YEAR FOR ITS ADULT FACILITIES
AND TWO MILLION FOR ITS JUVENILE
FACILITIES TO ADDRESS THESE
KINDS OF ISSUES --
WE HAVE SEEN A BACKLOG OF OUR
REPAIR PROJECTS GROW STARTING
FROM WHEN WE FIRST STARTED
MEASURING IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT R. FOUR
HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS TO OVER ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN SCOPE TO PROJECTS --
AND THAT'S IN ADDITION TO WHAT
WE BELIEVE IS A GREATER BACKLOG
THAT WE'VE REPORTED RECENTLY IN
THE MASTER PLAN.
AS MUCH AS THIRTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS.
THE DISCREPANCY BETWEEN THE TWO
IS THAT THE MILLION DOLLARS IS
THOSE PROJECTS THAT WE HAVE
SPENT A LOT OF TIME FOCUSED ON
GETTING SCOPE AND COST ESTIMATES.
I'M AND SO THIS BACKLOG HAS
GROWN AND WHAT WHAT IT AS
BECAUSE IN THE PRISONS.
IS -- SORT
OF THIS BREAK FIX RUN TO FAIL --
ROACH WHERE ARE OUR PRISONS ARE
TRYING TO FIX THE THINGS THAT
ARE BREAKING THAT DAY AND ARE
NOT BEING STRATEGIC IN SPENDING
TIME IN PREVENTIVE MAINTENANCE
BECAUSE ARE BEING --
RELOCATED --
TO THINGS THAT ARE BREAKING DOWN --
AROUND THEM.
AND I'M CERTAINLY DON'T HAVE
THAT THE RESOURCES --
WITHIN THE TWENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLAR NUMBER TO ADEQUATELY
TRYING TO INTERVENE IN THAT
BREAK SITE BREAK FIX CYCLE --
AND SO THIS REQUEST IN FRONT OF
YOU THIS TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR QUEST FOR TEN PROJECTS.
IS -- IN OUR
MIND SOME OF THE WORST MOST
IMMEDIATE --
CONDITIONS THAT THREATEN THE
SAVE.
OUR SECURE AND EFFECTIVE
OPERATION OF THE PRISONS --
EARLIER JONES SAWYER --
MENTIONED THAT --
YOU HAVE A ROOF LEAK IT HAS A
COLLATERAL IMPACT AND INDEED IT
DOES AND YOU'LL SEE IN THE
PROJECTS THAT WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF ROOFS AND WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
FLOORS --
THAT ARE FAILING AND THE FLOORS
ARE FAMILY BECAUSE WATER
INTRUSION --
IT'S CAUSING A GREAT DEAL OF
CALAMITY AND THE PRISONS --
IT'S CAUSING US TO HAVE TO SHUT
DOWN PROGRAM MOVE INMATES --
FROM HOUSING UNITS FROM MEDICAL
BADS AND SO PART OF THE REQUEST
HERE IS TO REPLACE SOME ROUGH
SAID A FEW OF OUR FACILITIES --
AND ALSO TO REPLACE SOME
FLOORING AT SOME OF THE IMPACTED
AREAS --
WHAT WE TRY TO DO IS IDENTIFIES?
SIX LIKE THAT THAT WE FELT WE
ABSOLUTELY HAD TO GET --
WORKING ON FOR THE VALUE OF THE
PRISON.
SYSTEM TO OPERATE EFFECTIVELY --
WE ALSO HAVE --
SOME REGULATORY ISSUES ON IN
HERE -- WE
HAVE SOME.
OF UPON IMPROVEMENTS AT ONE OF
OUR PRISONS WE'VE GOT --
A KITCHEN FIRE SUPPRESSION IT'S
REQUIRED AS PART OF A CODE AND
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE FIRE
SUPPRESSION THE KITCHENS --
THE FARMERS WILL HAVE SHUT DOWN
THE KITCHEN OPERATIONS AT ONE OF
OUR FACILITIES AND SO THEY'RE
TRYING TO MAKE DO WITH US SO
LIKE KITCHENS.
COOKING SO LIKE KITCHENS.
SO THE IMPACT OF THAT IS --
THE INCREASED COST OF FOOD
PREPARATION --
AND THE WAY THAT WE HAVE TO
PURCHASE FOOD INSTEAD OF LARGE
QUANTITY SMALLER SYSTEM --
PRE PACKAGED ITEMS THINGS LIKE
THAT SO IT HAS SAID IT
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT. TO US WHEN
THE FIRE MARSHAL COMES IT DOWN
AND SHUTS DOWN YOU KNOW FIVE OF
YOUR SATELLITE KITCHENS.
AND YOU ONLY HAVE YOUR YOUR MAIN
KITCHEN DO TO PREPARE FOOD AND
TO RE HEAT AND GET IT.
OVER TO THE FACILITIES FOR
SERVING YOU HAVE TO HAVE IT AT
CERTAIN TEMPERATURES SO IT'S
BEEN VERY VERY DIFFICULT FOR US
AND WE'RE WORKING THROUGH THOSE
ISSUES BUT WE HAVE TO GET THE
FIRE SUPPRESSION SYSTEM.
SO WE HAVE FIRE SUPPRESSION
SYSTEM FIRE ALARM SYSTEMS WHICH
ARE A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT --
AND THE FACT THAT WITHOUT A
PROPER FIRE ALARM SYSTEM ON A
BUILDING I HAVE TO HAVE STAFF.
AVAILABLE TO ON A WHAT WE CALL
FIRE WATCH SO WE'RE STILL WE'RE
PAYING ADDITIONAL COSTS FOR FIRE
WATCH VERSES IN ALARM SYSTEM WHO
SHOULD ALERT US. TO BE ABLE TO
RESPOND TO AN AREA SO MULTIPLE
FISH.
REALLY SIGNIFICANT PHYSICAL
PLANT CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE
SOME OF THESE BAD SAID --
DOUBLES TALKING ABOUT OUR
LICENSE MEDICAL BENEFITS.
AND YOU KNOW THE FEAR IS IS YOU
KNOW IMPACT IN OUR LICENSURE IN
OUR ABILITY TO CARE FOR THE
PATIENTS WITHIN THE FACILITY
VERSUS HAVING TO TRANSFER THEM
OUT INTO THE COMMUNITY.
HOSPITALS.
ANOTHER AREA OF SIGNIFICANT
CONCERN SOME OF THESE ARE ARE.
LARGE YOU KNOW I I KNOW MORE
ABOUT PHYSICAL PLANT DESIGN THAN
I CARE TO BECAUSE I'M NOT NOT
THAT GIRL BUT YOU KNOW WHEN YOU
HAVE A WHOLE.
THIS LARGE IN A PIPE THAT THAT
IS DOING YOUR HEATING AND
COOLING FOR YOUR INSTITUTION AND
IT'S YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY GALLONS A MINUTE OF WATER
LOSS THAT WE HAVE.
IT IT YOU KNOW IT CERTAINLY
IMPACT X. ONE SECTION OF PIPE.
YOU KNOW TEN FEET DOWN THE ROAD
THE PIPE IS BREAKING YET AGAIN
BECAUSE HE'S GO THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE INSTITUTION.
THAT UNDER GROUND A PHYSICAL
PLANT THAT IT WAS TALKING ABOUT
THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS THAT
IS PROBLEMATIC.
AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO BENEFIT
FROM THE SUPPLEMENTAL
APPROPRIATIONS IN YEARS PAST --
AND MOST PARTICULARLY WITH THE
REFER PLACEMENTS.
AND IT'S REALLY MY HOPE THAT
THIS BACKLOG WE START TO SEE IT --
DIMINISH OVER TIME BECAUSE WE'VE
HAD THIS INTERSECTION OF PUTTING
THE NECESSARY RESOURCES AND YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU CAN GET A WATER
TIGHT ENVELOPE OF A STRUCTURE.
YOU CAN START TO MAKE MEANINGFUL
REPAIRS ON THE INTERIOR BUT IT
YOU KNOW IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT
TO PUT --
ANY KIND OF INTERIORS --
REPAIRS IN PLACE AND THEN HAVE
THE ROOF --
LEAGUE SUBSTANTIALLY AND THEN
IT'S JUST DESTROYED ALL THAT
WORK SO --
YOU KNOW GETTING THAT WATER
TIGHT ENVELOPE IS IMPORTANT AND
IN -- SO SO
WE ARE HOPING THAT THE
COMBINATION OF THIS DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR HOUSE PLUS THE REGULAR.
AMOUNT THAT WE RECEIVED AS PART
OF SPECIAL PLAYER REPAIR.
PLUS YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THE
INCREASE TO THE FACILITY
OPERATIONS FUNDING.
WHICH WOULD.
IN OUR MINDS PROPERLY RESOURCE
THE TIONS PERSONNEL TO BE MORE
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN SOME OF THIS --
PERIODIC MAINTENANCE TO OUR
SYSTEMS THE COMBINATION OF ALL
OF THAT WE HOPE --
WILL START TO DRAMATICALLY
REDUCE THIS BACKLOG [inaudible]
ANY QUESTIONS.
ANY COMMENTS OF BURMA.
FINANCE [inaudible]
HELLO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
AT WE WE RECOMMENDED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECT THE
DEPARTMENT TO PROVIDE IT WITH A
LIST OF SPECIFIC PROJECTS THAT
WOULD LIKE TO UNDERTAKE WITH THE
PROPOSED THE REQUESTED TWENTY
FIVE MILLION.
AS WELL AS AN EXPLANATION OF HOW
IT PRIORITIZE THOSE PROJECTS THE
DEPARTMENT HAS SINCE PROVIDED A
LIST AND WHICH WE ARE REVIEWING%
AND WILL CERTAINLY NOTIFY THE
COMMITTEE IF.
WE IDENTIFY ANY CONCERNS WITH
THOSE PROJECTS --
IN ADDITION WE RECOMMEND TO
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THAT WE
THINK WOULD HELP BETTER ENABLE
LET A LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OF
ON GOING DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
ISSUES.
AT THE FIRST IS --
REQUIRING THAT APARTMENT
IDENTIFY HOW THEIR BACKLOG
CHANGES BETWEEN TWENTY NINETEEN
AND TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND TO
THE EXTENT THAT THE BACKLOG
GROWS OVER THAT PERIOD REQUIRING
CDC ARE TO IDENTIFY THE REASONS
FOR THAT GROWTH AS WELL AS WHAT
STRATEGIES IT'S TAKING TO
MITIGATE THAT.
I'M AND THEN SECOND REQUIRING
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
REPORT ON WHAT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS ARE
ULTIMATELY FUNDED WITH TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY FUNDS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NO THE COMMENTS IN OKAY THAT
ITEM WILL BE HELD OPEN REMOVED
TO THE FINAL ITEM WITH THIS ITEM
NUMBER.
THREE ISSUE THREE VARIOUS
CAPITAL OUTLAY IN FACILITY
IMPROVEMENT BUDGET PROPOSALS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE FINAL ISSUE IS A LISTING OF
OUR CAPITAL OUTLAY AND FACILITY
IMPROVEMENT PROPOSALS ARE
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT FOR THIS
ISSUE IS DEAN BORG HE'S THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF FACILITY
PLANNING CONSTRUCTION AND
MANAGEMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS --
DON'T GO AS QUICKLY AS I CAN
OVER THESE --
PROJECTS I UNDERSTAND THEY'RE
GONNA BE HELD OPEN --
THE FIRST OF SEVERAL PROJECTS
LISTED THERE ARE A HEALTHCARE
FACILITY IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM
PROJECTS AT FOR PRISONS --
LAST SURE APPROPRIATE FORTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS OF
ADDITIONAL LEASE REVENUE FUNDING
FOR THE HECK OF IT PROJECTS AND
AT THAT TIME WE ANALYZED OUR
EXISTING PROJECTS AND LOOK TO
SEE WHICH PROJECTS WERE MOST AT
RISK. FOR ADDITIONAL --
COST INCREASES AND WHAT WE
IDENTIFIED AT THESE FOR PRISONS
WERE OTHER REPORT PERFORMING
GENERAL CONTRACTOR FOR
PERFORMING A KNEE CONSULTANT AND
OR RENOVATION PROJECTS AND
BUILDINGS THAT WERE FIFTY FIVE
TO SIXTY FIVE YEARS OLD.
AND OUR EXPERIENCE AT OTHER
PRISONS THAT ALREADY TOLD US
THAT WHEN YOU GET INTO THOSE
BUILDINGS OF THAT AGE YOU FIND A
LOT OF THINGS IN THE CEILING AND
WALLS THAT YOU WEREN'T
ANTICIPATING AND THEN WITH THE
GENERAL CONTRACTOR OUT THERE.
IT'S LEADING TO A LOT OF
EXTENDED JOHN COSTS SO --
WE HAVE --
TAKEN THE PROJECTS OF THESE FOR
PRISONS OUT OF THE GENERAL
CONTRACTOR SCOPE AND PROPOSING
FUNDING IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET TO
DO THAT THROUGH THE IN MERRICK
WARD LABOR PROGRAM --
CONSTRUCTION METHOD --
STARTING NEXT FISCAL YEAR --
WHEN WE DO RUN INTO PROBLEMS IN
THERE ARE PROJECTS THE IN WHAT
WE'RE LABOR PROBLEMS PRO PROGRAM
DOES NOT HAVE AN EXTENDED
OVERHEAD CHARGE LIKE THE GENERAL
CONTRACTORS DO AND THEY WORK
MUCH CLOSER WITH THE PRISON IN
ORDER TO KEEP EXISTING
OPERATIONS GOING?
WELL THEY'RE DOING THIS WORKS WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS WILL HAVE A A
LONG TERM BENEFIT TO HAVING THE
LEAST REVENUE FUNDING APPROVED
LAST YEAR AGO FARTHER AS FAR AS
THE OTHER PROJECTS ARE CONCERNED --
MOVING ON FROM THAT HEALTHCARE
PROJECT --
WE DO HAVE --
CONSTRUCTION --
PREPARATION REQUEST --
FOR NEW YARD FOR INMATES AT
FACILITY DE I A PELICAN BAY
STATE PRISON THAT WAS A FORMER
SECURITY HOUSING UNIT THAT WAS
CONVERTED TO LEVEL TWO INMATES --
THREE POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS
TO PROVIDE THEM WITH --
PROPER YARD --
SPACE OUTSIDE THE BUILDING --
FOR THEIR RECREATION --
THE NEXT PROJECT IS THAT --
CORRECTIONAL TRAINING FACILITY
ON SOLEDAD --
THAT IS ADMINISTRATIVE
SEGREGATION CELL DOOR RETROFIT --
THIS IS THE LAST OF A SERIES OF
FOR PROJECTS THAT HAS DONE THIS
RETROFIT AT OTHER PRISONS THAT
SIMILARLY HAD BARRED FRONTS FOR
THEIR ADMINISTRATIVE SEGREGATION --
DOORS --
THIS IS JUST BEING COMPLETED
RIGHT NOW AT DUAL VOCATIONAL
INSTITUTION DOWN TO TRACY AND
IT'S A PRIMARY PURPOSE IS TO
IMPROVE --
SAFETY FOR BOTH THE INMATES IN
THE STAFF THAT ARE WORKING AND
LIVING IN THAT UNIT.
THE NEXT PROJECT IS AT FOLSOM
STATE PRISON --
IT'S NINE POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS TO ADDITIONAL WATER
STORAGE TANKS THAT WOULD SERVE
BOTH FOLSOM STATE PRISON AND
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON
SACRAMENTO --
THE THIS IS TO ADDRESS OUR FIRE
SUPPRESSION REQUIREMENTS THAT
WERE HIGHLIGHTED BY THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL DURING INSPECTIONS
AND PROJECT REVIEWS OF OUR
HEALTHCARE PROJECTS THAT WERE ON
GOING OUT AT THOSE TWO PRISONS.
THE NEXT PROJECT --
IS AT THE DAHLE LOCATIONAL
INSTITUTION OR TRACY IT'S A NEW
BOILER FACILITY OUR SYSTEM
BOILERS DO NOT MEET OUR QUALITY
STANDARDS SO THIS WILL --
CONSTRUCT --
SMALL BUILDING --
TO HOUSE OUR NEW BOILERS THAT
WILL ALLOW US TO BE IN --
COMPLIANCE WITH AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS.
THE NEXT OVER PROJECTS ARE ALL
THOSE PRECEDING ONES I'VE
MENTIONED WORK CONSTRUCTION OF
CORPORATIONS IS NEXT GROUP ALL
WE'RE ASKING FOR THE SECOND
PHASE OF DESIGN FUNDING THE SO
CALLED WORKING DRAWINGS FACE
FUNDING FOR PROJECTS THAT WERE
APPROVED.
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET ACT --
ONE OF THEM IS --
PROJECT THAT WOULD PROVIDE
MEDICATION PREPARATION AND
DISTRIBUTION IMPROVEMENTS AT
THIRTEEN SEPARATE PRISONS --
TO DRESS MISSING CHANGES AND
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAM EXPANSIONS --
ANOTHER PER PROJECT WOULD
PROVIDE I'M FOR SPECIFIED
HOUSING UNITS ARE HOUSING --
WHEN I'M OLDER PRISONS OF THE
MEDICALLY A COMPROMISE?
OLDER PRISONERS AND MEDICALLY
COMPROMISED PRISONERS --
AND INTO FACILITIES --
TO RENOVATE AND BUILD NEW
CLASSROOM FACILITIES AT
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON
SACRAMENTO AND SAN QUENTIN STATE
PRISON IN ORDER TO SUPPORT OUR
EXPANSION OF OUR EDUCATION
PROGRAMS.
ACROSS THOSE FOR PROJECTS IT'S A
TOTAL OF FIVE POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE SECOND PHASE OF
DESIGN.
NEXT IS THE THE ONE AT NEW OF
PROJECT THAT IS IN THIS YEAR'S --
BUDGET --
MADE IT DEALS WITH ARSENIC
ARSENIC IN GROUNDWATER IS
ENDEMIC TO MANY AREAS OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN OUR TO PRISONS
THAT ARE LOCATED NEAR MADERA
THEY SHARE FIVE WELLS THAT ARE
OF VARYING --
WATER QUALITY AS FAR AS THE
ARSENIC IS CONCERNED IN THE MOST
BLAND THE WATERS CURRENTLY IN
ORDER TO MEET WATER QUALITY
STANDARDS BUT EVEN IN OUR BETTER
WELLS THE ARSENIC LEVELS ARE
INCREASING.
SO -- OVER
ABOUT THREE TO FIVE YEARS WILL
BE IN A POSITION WHERE BLENDING
WON'T EVEN MEET OUR STANDARDS
ANY LONGER.
SO WE HAVE --
REQUESTED ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
TO BEGIN THE DESIGN PROCESS TO
BUILD AN ARSENIC A TREATMENT
PLANT -- FOR
THE WATER THERE IT WOULD SERVE
BOTH OF THOSE STRUCTURED.
AND THEN FINALLY --
THE LAST ITEM ON THE AGENDA IS A
ADDITIONAL ROOF --
REPLACEMENTS --
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
LEGISLATORS FUNDED ON A LARGE
SCALE ROOF REPLACEMENT SEVEN
NUMBER PRISONS AND THIS WOULD
JUST BE CONTINUING THAT PROGRAM
SO REQUEST TWO MILLION DOLLARS
AND TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY IN
ORDER TO DO THE DESIGN EFFORTS
AT HIGH DESERT STATE PRISON
THEIR SUSANVILLE.
IN CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON
SOLANO NEAR BACK OF BILL AND
THEN IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET THERE WOULD BE SIXTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WOULD FUND
THE ROOF REPLACEMENTS AT THOSE
TWO LOCATIONS.
THIS IS WHERE WE GO IN AND ALL
THE SINGLE PLY ROOFING THAT ARE
AND DO ALL THE GRADING SOME
ACTIVELY LEAKING OTHERS ARE JUST
AROUND THE CORNER THIS WILL --
AND THE FACE PROJECT REPLACE ALL
OF THOSE ROOFS --
SO WILL BE IN A BETTER SITUATION
ONCE THAT IS COMPLETED AT THOSE
TWO PRESENTS --
AVAILABLE ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT THOSE PROJECTS ANY
COMMENTS FROM --
FINANCE OR LA YOU.
A CHRISTIAN BUILDER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JUST WANT
TO CLARIFY ON A ONE OF THE
THINGS ON THE AGENDA FOR THE
MEDICAL DISTRIBUTION FACE TO
PROJECTS IT SAYS ON THE AGENDA
THAT IS BEING FUNDING FOR DESIGN
AND CONSTRUCTION.
IN FACT --
AS DEAN SAID IT IS WORKING
DRAWING FEEDS THE PROJECTS I
JUST WANTED TO MAKE THAT
CLARIFICATION CORRECTION.
THANK YOU ANYTHING ANY OTHER
COMMENTS ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT ITEM
WILL BE HELD OVER WELL THANK YOU.
WITH THE END OF OUR AGENDA --
AT THIS TIME WILL --
Là MISS MELINDA'S TO VOTE.
ITEM NUMBER.
ONE OF ON THE VOTE ONLY ITEM ON
THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT EIGHTY NINE FORTY
ITEMS THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE
[inaudible]
ONE MELENDEZ [inaudible]
OKAY.
THAT'S NOW OUT WITH THE FIVE A
VOTE -- THIS
IS NEXT ITEM --
I DIDN'T ISSUE NUMBER TWO
STATEWIDE ADVANCED PLANS AND
STUDIES.
MELENDEZ.
ADD THAT NOW IS FIVE VOTES SO
IT'S OUT ON A FIVE OH VOTE.
OF VOTE NUMBER THREE ISSUE
NUMBER THREE FACILITIES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM EXPANSION [inaudible]
MELENDEZ.
OKAY THAT'S NOW FIVE OH VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEETING IS
ADJOURNED